my question is what Shaq do next red try
just awesome to education chef Bob
that's really your question can I
challenge you guys on this webinar here
is it okay if I challenge all of you
since it's only four of you is it okay
if I push all of your buttons can I do
that you got all these videos on value
timing that I answered this question and
you asked me a question about what it is
to whether I should go to college or not
Bob I have a video called whether you
should stay in school or drop out okay a
video club with you should sing okay
then so when you watch that video what
did you get from it that I answered your
question
whether you should stay in school or
drop out tell me then drop out it is
that simple though it is that simple
though you got it so so if you watch the
video and and and you know you're a
worker okay and you know your work and
you know you're wired and you know your
wife to be an entrepreneur and you know
you're not afraid of hard work meaning
you're not afraid of working day and
night and you love sales you love
selling you have a product you have a
job you have a way of making money you
catch yourself in class falling asleep
you're bored out of your mind you can't
even keep your mind together the only
subject that matters to you is a couple
of different subjects and you don't
understand why you have to take Fine
Arts or physics or you know biology some
of these things that you'll never use in
your mind and your major is business why
would you go to school now on the other
hand if you're going to school because
you want to be an engineer it's probably
good idea to go to school if you're
going to school because you want to be a
doctor so dentist a you want to go into
politics one day and you would like to
have a degree because you want to be a
lawyer you should go to school but if
it's business and you're wired to want
to go into business 80% of college
students today should drop out period
now here's the other part Bob you said
how old are you you're 18 or 19 how are
you and 80 okay Bob can you go back to
school at 20
- sure sure yeah
can you go back to school at 30 - you
could so can you get married at 40 I
promise your sperms gonna be working my
buddy is my buddy's my butt is 45 years
old 48 years old and he had a kid his
daughter's five years old he's right
next door to us
so you just need to make sure you keep
exercising so your sperm is working even
at that age I mean Donald Trump is seven
years old he's got a 12 year old son
Benny says runners were working at 57
years old but let me tell you what I'm
going with this with it with the point
I'm making to you there is this there is
this concept of thinking so you know
like oh my gosh you know I'm gonna go
out there and I'm gonna follow this
system to the tee and and then it's
gonna work for me a hundred percent at a
time and I have to get me luck I
remember when growing up my father was
nearly four years older than my mom I
thought you had to marry somebody that
was four oh four years older than your
mom because that's what was fed into my
mind the husband should be four years
old it's a bunch of [ __ ] right you
need to get married buy latest you know
I I had a man that told me if you don't
get married by age 28 you're a menace to
society I disagree with that if you
don't get married to men to somebody at
before 20 of your menace to society what
if I get married earlier and then it
doesn't work out and they get a divorce
and I don't know how to be a father and
I got two kids with the woman that's not
got an ex-wife and that kid is gonna
grow up without a mom and daddy being
together and what if I did that mistake
and I got married earlier so people say
you got to go to school to get a degree
for what because that's what society
wants you to do well what if I go to
school and I'm you know annoyed after
four years of wasting time and I could
have done something with business that's
a waste of my time so I think Bob you
have two choices one if you don't know
how to work hard if you are not someone
who is willing to work your tail off
stay in school stay in school okay I
promise you if how many hours a week do
you play video games Bob
I maybe play that for five zero for five
hours on Sundays you play four to five
hours of video games
that shit's gotta be out the window just
so you know that's gotta be out the one
you gotta throw those video games out
the window number two you smoke weed you
do you do you party way too much are you
like hanging out with guys that are way
too much into partying and they're
distracted yeah okay that's good good so
that the video game needs to be out you
need to get fully obsessed how many
books or content do you study on a
weekly basis how much are you immersing
your mind to subject before I was
reading but right now something changes
some in me I think I got lazy in the way
yeah good I stopped reading but if I I
think if I have time I should I should
just use the time to read so I I read
books
Warren reading right now that's good so
let me say this to Bob let me say this
to you it sounds like you need to stay
in college okay and let me tell you you
you just answered it when I asked you
about hard work you said I'm being lazy
right now let me tell you what I would
if I'm staying in college right now one
take the accounting classes take any
class that's only around business okay
don't don't take any classes that are
your what do you call it you know that
you're supposed to take two graduates
electives or what did it come you like
what do you call it
electives that you got to take don't
take any electives don't waste your time
with any electives or any of that stuff
take stuff that's going to help you with
business
think take finance take any business
management courses find out who is the
best teacher in the clinda university
that ran a business before going attend
that person's class don't go like find
out who the teachers are I'm more
interested in who the teacher is so I
would go and find out from the teacher
and said have you ever ran a business
before yes was it successful yes did you
sell it yes I want to be in your class
going those people's classes don't go
into people that just have theories and
they're gonna sit down and tell you
about how capitalism sucks and rich
people are greedy don't even waste your
time being around people like that but
take courses of people that ran a
business before and then meanwhile
meanwhile Bob developed discipline
because there's one thing I do know you
have let me tell you what you do have
you're extremely entertaining you are
extremely entertaining you are extra you
got a big personality you're a lot of
fun I can tell you a lot of you got a
sense of humor you're charming you got
charm you got charisma I saw your video
while I buy a Tim when you started with
the whole way and you're doing the whole
thing and and and and you got the whole
magic man you got the magic with the
personality but sometimes guys with
personalities like yours are extremely
secretly lazy very very lazy because
their talent typically gets them to
where they're currently at and your
talent alone is not going to get you to
the next level so stay in school still
go take those basic courses that you're
taking that have to do with business
make sure the professors are people that
ran a business before and only go to
them for now and then sometimes on a way
to dream you get lost and find a bigger
one which means the next three six
twelve months kind of study yourself see
what behaviors are taking place see
what's inspiring you see what's taking
place with you instead of playing those
video games spend those four or five
hours reading books drop some stuff that
are waste your time don't watch TV shows
and cartoons that do no service to you
yeah I talked to someone last week which
was also a millionaire rather
international business and he told me to
take the worse and take what could I
take pick what did work not too low a
detour got it detour yeah because he
said something that got me thinking that
he said on the except if you go to your
balls straight in a straight line you
will miss all the things beside you you
know you know I mean if you think itõs
maybe you can find the things around you
and you can enjoy it that way maybe the
maybe the way to goal is more important
and actually get to the goal no I mean
sure sure awesome well Bob let's go to
the next question guys absolutely buddy
take the lead nomination
[Music]
[Laughter]
first of all you like you see more
interactive things like this with
subscribers you see it's turning into a
stronger brand more case studies I love
the case studies writer what else oh I
love those
what do you see it going like another
ball for the million subscribers Nick
listen that's a great question and it's
a fun question to answer because my I
completely want to contribute towards
revolutionising the educational system
we have a book that's coming out that
has to do with the whole drop out or
stay in school the book is going to be
called drop out and gets cold and it's
extremely controversial extremely
controversial that'll be coming out here
soon
and I have a feeling this thing's gonna
tick off a lot of people which is good
it's I'm looking forward to having this
book start a new dialogue amongst
professors academia universities
teachers parents kids everybody I want
everybody thinking about our current
educational system that we have around
the world and then the other part is the
fact that you know I fully agree and
believe that the world is a better place
with more entrepreneurs I fully believe
that i 100% believe the world is a
better place if we have more
entrepreneurs and if we can figure out a
way to create a community around the
world if we can figure out a way to
create a community around the world that
comes together and learns how to enhance
their business to the next level and we
can do it on a grander scale I can only
imagine what we can do to the world's
unemployment rates that we have and what
we can do to some of the people that are
living in societies where they're
economical system is not necessarily a
capitalistic system maybe they're living
in a socialistic or communistic system
ran by a dictator that doesn't allow the
individual to take their ideas that they
have that we have been stre no holding
on to and I want I want that guy to let
loose I want that guy to spread his
wings or her wings and fly away and show
the world what inventions they're gonna
bring that's gonna make this world a
better place I want that person to also
have the ability to share their talents
with the world the other part is I mean
I would love to see young cats like
Bablu
who one day could be the next Jack Ma
and even even if they even if a video
like this or a channel like this
inspires Ababu to talk to a guy like me
who typically doesn't talk to him like
that he typically doesn't have guys that
push him around and you know and say
what the hell you ask me a question for
I bet a lot of people don't talk to him
like that so he's gonna grow up thinking
life is all you know good and dandy
until all of a sudden Wham somebody hits
him in the face and snap out of it and
he becomes a man he grows up a little
bit or even a Shahin Teti who's sitting
there with his ideas a virtual reality
is questioning something that what if we
can make this thing better and
experience virtual reality at the
highest level with business
that's that part and the other thing
would value Taemin is you know I grew up
in a family where my mother side they
were 100% Communists and my father's
side they were all imperialist and I was
born in Iran and I was born in a place
where there was a lot of bombing I
remember getting bombed 167 times in a
day you better believe that create a lot
of anxiety and fear in me as a kid and I
lived in Iran till 10 and then we
escaped and we lived in Germany for
couple years at a refugee camp and then
from there coming to America and going
to school where school for me was
miserable and I joined the army
afterwards and I just kind of said well
you know I'm not the smartest cat I'm
not the you know I'm not this I'm not
that I'm just gonna go join a military
and be in a military for a while and
then all of a sudden I get a hold of
books business books and next thing you
know this guy that nobody would have bet
on to become somebody in his life in
high school no one would have put money
on PBD these different events come
together and inspire you know me to make
a decision that I could possibly go out
and build a life that I dream about
building and then this happens and there
are millions of other Patricks or
Jennifer's or Mary's or Bob's out there
that are waiting for the similar type of
an inspiration so vitamins eventually
cuz the more we're doing these types of
things the more you were getting demand
for people to say Pat we want more
one-on-one time you know the videos are
great we're getting a lot from the
videos but I want some one-on-one time
so we're most likely going to eventually
be doing three-day conferences for
entrepreneurs to come from around the
world where thousands of people will
come and we'll cover everything from
what it is to be a CEO a test you got to
take to find out if you are CEO or CFO
or CEO or president or an investor or
salesperson or biz that person and who
do you need to recruit and how do you
need to recruit them how do you raise
money and I'm gonna bring investors
there and private equity group guys
there and you know introduce you to guys
that have money and have them talking
about how to erase capital and you know
how to make your idea better we're gonna
put conferences like that around the
world when we're gonna do that I don't
know because I'm still running a
full-time company that's growing
aggressively fast we had our biggest
year we've ever had in history the
company and I do have three kids under
the age of five so and I'm doing
taemin so my time is pretty crazy right
now but that's probably where it's gonna
lead to next that kind of thing and then
you know I want to college you know what
I want to Michigan State and you know I
have a business degree and they do teach
you some things about entrepreneurship
they have hot producer prices but they
don't even they don't teach you the
simple basics of you know incorporating
the business they won't make they tell
you the different ways from fourth grade
like you know if you're going to be
ahead of CES Forbes before that kind of
thing but as far as like going you know
to your state's website it came out of
your name exists and and all of that
other kind of stuff they don't they
don't do that and that's like my
business and you know it's crazy those
things don't exist so I mean I think
what you're doing and help that cause a
lot and I also shape the world in the
future or far as well yeah I would tell
you this I would take this as well that
eventually the goal is to start
universities there's gonna be an
entrepreneur University that'll be
started that will completely
revolutionize the way we educate and
teach entrepreneurs around the world can
you imagine you go on a website where
you get to see who the instructor is
before you take the class for instance
you get to look at the profile and the
instructor says I have been a founder of
a company before enough sold it before
for over ten million dollars so you know
that's the person that's teaching
wouldn't you want to learn from that guy
right or you have an instructor that you
know was a CEO of a company and helped
the company go from three million
dollars of revenues to hundred million
dollar
if you want to learn from that guy or an
attorney who went through certain
lawsuits and you can find out how this
guy started a law firm that ended up
being you know something significantly
big you want to study from that guy but
you can find out about their past on
what they did we would eventually start
a university that's purely to give birth
to the next lift guys I don't want to
unveil everything that I'm working on
I'm gonna have a book coming out here
soon
that's a fiction book took me five years
to write this fiction book once you guys
read this fiction book you're not gonna
you're gonna think I'm a bit crazy and
I'm a bit off so that's why I'm kind of
delaying that part before you realize
how crazy we are about our vision on
what we want to do and value taming is
gonna become a very big movement around
the world so hang tight before you hears
about some of these things being
unveiled you're one of the first to know
it because I haven't really talked about
this publicly but it's only five of us
on this call and this video may even end
up being alive who knows but the point
being there's some big things we're
working on right now so Jonathan you got
to drop the wheat though man I got to
tell you me you got to drop the wheat in
the video games man if you're joking if
you're joking great but if you're not
joking here's the only reason I would
say about wheat I think cigarettes are
more dangerous than wheat quite frankly
because cigarette is you know man-made
and actually we can be God made because
you're raising wheat so I think if any
one of them needs to be legal it's
actually weed over cigarettes I think
cigarettes needs to be illegal
I think weed needs to be legal and I
don't smoke either one of them but for
me it's it's also my opinion about
alcohol I used to drink a lot when I was
in the army because I partied a lot and
I was chasing skirts all the time and
anytime you drink three shots of tequila
you just have better pickup lines if you
know what I'm talking about I don't know
how it is dinner next thing you know
your pickup line you have some smooth
pickup on his that show up when you say
man what did not line come out and I
should write it somewhere and use it
again in the future but okay man I'm
glad you're joking man that the weed is
gonna slow you down man I'm telling you
weed slows you down
I don't wanted to get your reaction hi
well you got a reaction if that's what
you were looking for you got yourself a
reaction man you got yourself a reaction
we also have another one about
compensating like those people but what
is it your best technique that you use
or recruiting those people what is the
best technique to recruit great
salespeople meaning I'm already sitting
in front of them or how do I find great
sales because it's the two different
things okay
well let's first let's first talk about
how to find great salespeople so it goes
the same thing man how do you find
really hot girls really hot girls
typically have what type of friends what
Instagram Oh buddy man I'm starting to
get an idea who you are man you got
yourself a sense of humor here but no
think about it think about it this way
though think about it this way how do
you really find hot girls hot girls
typically have hot friends right I mean
when you go to you know when you go out
and you would see the one girl who's
very pretty she would have four other
friends that were also very pretty for
instance you know a high school
quarterback who's the stud of high
school doesn't hang out with 4.7 GPA
kids at least not all the time he hangs
out with the receiver with the baseball
player etc etc so the same way that you
have hot girls who have hot friends is
the same way that great salespeople have
great friends who are great in sales so
the moment I find someone who's great in
sales I asked them who else they know
who's great in sales
I've always leveraged great sales people
to introduce me to other great
salespeople it's very similar to
competitive people sometimes I'll take a
competitive guy over somebody who's
great and sell so I look for people who
have had backgrounds of sports if the
guy used to play sports before and he's
an absolute beast of a competitor let's
just say this guy is so competitive that
Heat
wants to crush everybody's number he
can't help himself and you can see it in
his eyes his Bloods boiling he wants to
compete
give me that guy I can teach that guy
how to be great in sales over somebody
who's got 20 years of sales experience
that's one now let's talk about the
other part how do you actually bring
somebody in sales onboard to want to
work with you one you yourself
gotta have an example of success so if
you ain't making money no one wants to
work with somebody that doesn't have
money so if you're a five you may
recruit an eight but you can only keep
an eighth for about a month because that
eight is eventually going to realize
you're a five and he leaves and goes
finds an eight and a half now if you
take your five and you raise it to seven
you can probably recruit a six and a
half seven but if you get a nine and a
half or you get an eight and a half that
eight and a half if you're not paying
them well and he's not making a lot of
money is gonna go somewhere else
depending if your sales manager it's
different if your to see on the founder
of the company because at that point you
can get a sales manager who's in nine
and a half that's mentor and all these
other guys and and driving all these
other guys so it all depends on that
part are you making money do you have
success are you an incredible coach
yourself that's very good at teaching
other people about how sales works the
other part is when someone looks at you
and you're sitting down talking to them
a great recruiter knows how to challenge
the opposition's position let me say it
one more time a great recruiter knows
how to challenge the opposition's
position what does this mean let you see
I'm sitting with Bobby and I'm sitting
and I'm trying to recruit a guy named
Bobby who does sales right now let's
pick a place he that sells for jewelry
okay he sells watches for Rolex and he's
one of the top guys at Rolex and he last
year he made 83,000 dollars
hypothetically hypothetically and I'm
sitting there and I'm doing insurance
I'm doing financial services I'm doing
real estate I'm doing pharmaceutical
sales I'm doing gym sells I don't know
pick a product what you're selling and I
sit down and I say Bobby how long do you
see yourself doing this what you're
doing right now do you see yourself
doing in the next five 10 15 20 years I
don't but I like it right now what do
you like about it
I like the fact that I'm making very
good money I said do you like the fact
that you're making more money than your
cousins and siblings or do you like the
fact that you're just making you know
some money to get a nice car and nice
toy and nice watch to impress some
people because you know there's a
difference on who you're comparing
yourself to are you making above quarter
million are you making above half a
million or are you just making more than
your friends and relatives are then you
know this body language and he gets a
little uncomfortable and it's okay there
that stunk a little bit didn't it yes it
did okay so are you happy or you content
and they say I'm happy oh you're happy
yes tell me why I think you're happy and
then this person is gonna tell you well
because I'm making money I Drive a nice
car I'm you know doing this I'm doing
that I'm doing this then I say okay so
you said you're happy yes so do you
already have three hundred thousand
dollars in a bank
no do you already live in a nice house
on a cul-de-sac no what's your favorite
place to travel to I'd love to go to
Italy have you gone there lately I have
not so do you want to go to Italy or do
you just want to go to Vegas and take a
picture in front of that Paris hotel and
tell everybody went to Paris but it was
really Vegas what do you want to do and
then he'll say no I want to go to Italy
I said so it sounds like you're more
content not necessarily happy Bobby if
you want to be content you don't need to
work with me if you want to be happy I'm
the guy to work with what do you want to
be so it also comes across on how you
recruit people to come on board and want
to work with you a great CEO great
founder or great sales managers a great
recruiter and knows how to push the
button that other people don't have the
audacity to do so I think I give you
plenty of answer for that one you can do
a lot with those things that I covered
with you more you may not be a bad idea
to actually do video on this because
we've never done a video on this before
we can we can stay off the Weed Man I'm
just telling you men stay off the weed
you're not mossy I wanted these big
events eventually almost at one of our
conferences and you're gonna come up and
we're gonna talk and I'm gonna tell you
dude just stop smoking that stuff I'm
gonna give you a hard time I will not
forget this day just so you know this
because you pulled a prank on me I'm on
a double prank you one of these days
let's do this hang tight for the
question I want to go to Jason and then
I'll come back to you to see if he got
any questions if he doesn't then I'll
come back to you I'm sorry I was going
to say Jonathan I think I think
Jonathan's on a smoke break Jonathan you
sound like your coffin man you know it
let us know if you want to join us here
so Jonathan is muted for whatever reason
he's got the mic is muted let me see if
I can arm you Jonathan
unmute Jonathan Jonathan you're
officially unmuted can you hear us
it says Jonathan is here but we don't
have okay since we don't have them let's
go back to the other questions the
client like I know I know you know you
guys with the insurances and everything
like that what is what has been the best
way that your selfie wasn't out
prospectin to the client Jason what's
your product aimed towards teachers and
that's one of the projects I'm working
on right now can do like a virtual oh
you haven't launched it yet
is that what you're saying that you
haven't launched it yet so who is your
customer tell me who's your customer
parents and teachers are your customer
yes okay so you're asking how to find
more customers right is what you're
asking
yeah okay you yeah so again magenta goes
back to Jason you the guy that did the
video with your twin it wasn't a twin
but you kind of made the two of you and
you have enjoy capitalism on you know we
almost picked you to come here live we
almost picked you a you you I hate to
say but you were like 11 spot you were
next to come in joining us here I don't
want to rub it in but you were 11 spot
and in first non qualifier was you for
what it's worth man but let me let me go
back to the question you asked look
anything I do anything I do and anything
I'm looking for it doesn't matter what
it is let's just say if I'm looking for
a hypothetical you know this is a guy
back in the days who used to bring
players to Nike Adidas and converse
maybe you know this story maybe you
don't know this story it's the Italian
mafia guy that brought Michael Jordan to
Nike I don't know if you know this story
so this guy what he did for a living he
would go to high schools and he would
look at top talent he would go to high
schools and he would look at top talent
and he would pay them $300 for shoes and
he would pay them a hundred dollars and
it would get him you know food and all
this other stuff so he won the loyalty
of these fourteen year old kids 15 year
old kids I look up the name afterwards
he he look up he would get their loyalty
and they would stay with him from 14
till 18 and then at 18 he already had so
much loyalty with them that all these
recruiters from universities would go
through him because he knew everybody
and eventually one day this guy goes to
Nike and he's sitting with the Nike
people and he tells Nike says look Nike
at that time in 1983 their philosophy
was they were paying ten players $50,000
a year endorsement contract 10 players
50k year that socialistic philosophy
just think about it they were paying ten
guys 50k and
this guy came and he says look stop
doing this
he says converse has magic Johnson bird
and everybody else at that time Congress
was the shoe for basketball players he
says we got to pay half a million
dollars to one guy his name is Michael
Jordan he says but this guy's gonna make
you a lot of money and Nike almost
didn't do it but they finally said yes
they paid a half a million dollars to
Mike there's never been an endorsement
contract bigger than that at that at
that time and then Mike becomes Air
Jordan and and Mike nowadays his shoes I
don't know what the number is 22 billion
I don't know it's a massive number that
I read the other day that it's big now
now what what's this got to do with the
question you ask it's very simple if I'm
a recruiter for college or MBA guess who
I want to know I want to know that
Italian mafia guy cuz he knows all the
talent okay if I want to know if I want
to date a girl and have her be my
girlfriend and I really like this girl
she's like the she's the girl that you
want to have as a girlfriend girlfriend
I want to make sure everybody around her
knows and likes me everybody her mom her
dad her best friend her teacher her
softball coach her personal trainer if
she's got a pastor her pastor doesn't
matter I want everybody that's around
her to like me because if they like me
guess what they're gonna tell her how
you should think about that guy Patrick
he's a good guy you should you should
think about this guy Patton watch Bob
Bob Bob Q right now Bob who was taking
notes right now eighteen year old kid in
high school he's trying to land that
girl Michelle was a cheerleader in his
school and you know he's fantasizing
about her Bob turn off the porn right
now man stay focused on this video that
we're having so so so this is a question
man Jason wherever teachers and parents
are you need to be wherever if teachers
and parents have a PTA meeting
you have to be there if there's a soccer
practice you gotta be there if there's
soccer leagues you gotta be a part of it
if there is anything and everything that
has to do with parents and teachers
being there you need to be there so take
out a sheet of paper
and make a list of all these guys where
they're going to be and make sure you're
at every single one of them make sure
they all know who you are
make sure they all know your product
then after that here's the next part
here's the next part you kind of hog in
this webinar which is okay
here's the next part here's the next
part let me tell what the next part is
the next part is if you can land the
most influential person as a customer
you have them all if you can land the
most influential person out of the
soccer moms or whatever to become a
customer of yours you have them all
that's really the game plan if you do
that you're getting all of them you got
a buddy you gotta do we have Jonathan
grant on now I can man I can foreclose
houses for banks and management
companies that I've been doing it about
for years man and I'm one of those guys
man I kind of been winging winging it
you know and I built it up and we do
about $300,000 a year with this business
and the thing is my my big mistake is I
stayed small too small and and now you
know I'm actually I've joined PSV and I
wanted to change this and you know enter
into that more and I kind of have so
much going on right now and not too much
structure with my business and I'm
trying to figure out how can I do it all
right now
well what are you doing right now make
the list of things that you do right now
and then and then also tell me how many
hours you're dedicating to each one per
week my business probably still at least
eighty eighty to I was working my
business you know I stopped considering
myself entrepreneur man I just other but
I'm self-employed now because I do so
much inside the business working in the
business got it so you do 80 80 hours a
week on the foreclosure side of the
business and you're doing 300k per year
is that top-line revenue is that net is
how you keeping the 300 how much of that
are you keeping okay so I did a 300
you're netting 180 yeah so you said your
business what do you think you're worth
and don't don't don't give me that don't
give me the commercial answer like this
is where this you know don't give me the
I'm priceless like Master Card
commercial answer you know I'm I'm
talking like really what do you think
you can be be honest your insecurities
fears all that stuff you know none of us
are perfect we all have insecurities
what do you truly think you're worth you
think you're getting paid more than what
you're worth or you're getting paid less
than what you're worth yes oh really so
you think you're worth more yeah what
what do you think you're worth
at least a million nett or top line and
so how come you're not how come you're
not making it
lack of think that's the only thing
that's what you're thinking okay what
are you doing right now to be improving
Jonathan grant like what's your plan to
be improving Jonathan grant joined a few
courses online just business courses
trying to I get more and more business
knowledge and just trying to change my
proud people that I associate with got
it okay what what books have you read
have you read a myth a myth has gotta be
at the top your list because sounds like
you have an organizational issue and you
need systems a myth a myth is the number
one book you need to read next period
that book needs to be at the top of your
list to get your systems in place with
your business but you know Jonathan
there's a there's the other part you got
to also be thinking about uh uh there's
other part you got to be thinking about
as well if you were really worth a
million you'd be making it right now
you'd be really making a right now you
would like to make a million dollar your
income but if you were worth it you'd be
making it right now what you're worth
today is exactly 180 net to you and
that's why you're making it yeah because
if you really believe that you're not
worth 180 there's no way in the world
you wouldn't be making 180 right now no
way in the world that's not possible
that would change because and how does
one increase their value think about how
do we increase our value how do we
increase our value in anything we do how
does one increase their value in
anything they do for instance you look
at the game of a youth sports guy you
look like you
sports guy I mean you pushed posted your
video with your kid are you a sports guy
who do you like what do you like what
what sports are you you follow the most
who do you like in basketball what's
your team almost threw up
did you see that like it almost like you
like it I almost threw up man
Houston Rockets listen I was oh good man
listen Houston rocket when you guys had
a chemo Lodge on Vernon Maxwell and you
know Cassell and all those guys Kenny
that was an exciting team you guys said
James Harden to me he can't leak he's
you can't build a team around him to win
a championship I don't think you can I
may be wrong but I don't think he I
think he needs to be too I don't think
it can be a 1 and LeBron is you know
LeBron are you bandwagon type of fan man
are we learning a lot about you like are
you just like joining though ok all
right cool no good now let me ask you a
question let me ask you a question
honestly do you think if Shaq would have
improved this free throws to 72% ok and
he would have improved his his health
you know and his diet where he would
have stayed more discipline and his work
ethic was better do you think Kobe and
him would have clash as much as they did
they would've still clash but probably
not at the levels that they did cuz you
know what Kobe's biggest complaint was
Kobe was a workaholic and Shaq was a fun
loose happy-go-lucky type of guy and you
know but Shaq would come in to the
season out of shape and Shaq's free
throws would be 55% to 60% and look
that's a lot of free throws you're
missing if you keep missing those three
threats a lot of them you're missing
right so if Shaq would have improved it
he would have probably had five or six
championships instead of four
championships maybe even more I think
the Shaq Kobe
you know duo was the greatest duel in
the history of basketball even if people
say Scottie Jordan I put Shaq and Kobe
ahead I think ego got in the way with
those guys and Scottie and you know
Jordan didn't have that challenge
because they were both willing to work
hard so you got to make a decision to up
your game you got to make a decision to
recreate yourself if you truly want to
get to a million dollar your income you
need to understand that your potential
can get to a million your no problem but
you today are not going to make a
million dollar your income with the way
you think today you're not gonna make it
you need to shift the thinking your
business need some systems your business
needs some structures to be able to
scale that business and then there's
sometimes the honest course you need to
ask which the question is is this really
the business I need to be a part of for
the long term five ten fifteen twenty
years from now or do I need to adjust
and look at some other industries that's
a whole different topic but I'm more
focused on you as an individual on how
you can improve yourself so guys we got
four minutes left I'll do one more
question and we'll wrap up this anybody
have one question that you really really
want to ask before we wrap up this
webinar here yes yes go ahead you guys
are so sweet man can somebody ask a
question man my gosh you want to be
entrepreneurs and you're dis sweet to
each other man send them a box of
chocolate if you want to holy [ __ ]
that's a good question I got two for you
here let's start there let's start there
I got two books for you to think as a
job of CEO take the top off just take
those things off yeah one is called
growing pains this is a very technical
book so don't expect to be excited this
is not a book that you're gonna read and
you're gonna say oh my gosh that was a
great motivational story it is
this is not that book this is a very
boring book but you need to read it as a
CEO growing pains okay
the other one is scaling up now this
you're gonna like it's mastering the
Rockefeller habits you guys know who
Rockefeller is how a few companies make
it and why the rest don't this is a very
very powerful book scaling up I don't
know if you guys can see it or not I
mean you pretty much will see what it
looks like okay
all good those are the two books I would
tell you as a CEO no you know I get
offers you know pad I'll give you a
hundred thousand dollars I'll give you
fifty times we get a lot of a lot of big
offers and I'm just I'm just saying no
to it right now I'm just saying no to it
right now maybe one day maybe soon but
just not right now I have a feeling
because of the amount of emails we get
we get thousands of requests on a weekly
basis to have do one-on-one sessions
sometimes businesses want to pay us a
hundred thousand dollars to do
consulting meetings with them and their
board of directors all this stuff maybe
in the next 90 days we'll launch
something because amount of requests
we're getting but at this point I'm not
taking too many people right now so the
answer at this point would be no but
hang tight
maybe we'll launch something in mix
three to six months so you and I are
sleeping together and I don't even know
about it
this this this this this this webinar
got pretty intimate pretty quick human
disguise it's got awkward pretty quick
we've thought we found out that Jason
likes to smoke weed and play video games
right now you tell him you sleep with me
there's a lot of strange things going on
here but look on a side note just to
tell you anything if you're gonna get
addicted to anything this is a good
channel to get addicted to and if it's
producing content
helping you grow your business that's
what gives me joy when I hear stories of
you guys growing your business I don't
ask you for hey Patti
you know guys send me $20,000 I'll
consult you I'm not asking that we it's
people there are a lot of online people
that hate value tainment that you cannot
you have no idea how many people hate
value tainment because I'm taking their
business away because I'm giving it away
for free I get a lot of hate mail we get
a lot of hate emails of people saying
you should stop doing these videos and
just let us sell it for thousand dollars
to our viewers and I say no I'm not
doing that not right now not right now
yeah I will most likely continue doing
videos like this for one more year I
don't know if I'm gonna do it for
forever but I guarantee I would go one
more year in 2017 so guys with that
being said hey listen let me take out
something before we wrap up you have no
idea how much I appreciate you guys even
though I give you a hard time I push you
around whatever I appreciate you guys
tremendously for the fact that you have
the courage to want to become an
entrepreneur make the world a better
place and the fact that you take your
life and business seriously you're
contributing to society in the world in
a way that cannot be measured and I and
I applaud you for that the fact that you
have the courage to do that you ought to
be very proud of yourself so from me to
you thank you so much for helping us get
to a hundred thousand next goal is a
quarter million than a million subs have
a wonderful day everybody look forward
to next time we meet take care guys bye
bye
[Music]